suis fou de patrick timsit voilà je
voulais dire patrick un jour je vais te
faire un aveu même on s'y retrouver dans
le même supermarché a acheté le dit
j'étais pas connu du tout est en fait et
je t'ai suivi dans tous les rayons non
j'ai voulu voir tout ce que tu as acheté
et je voulais acheter la même chose pour
être aussi drôle que toi j'ai eu peur je
me voyais dans un supermarché en train
de présenter des boîtes en avril suivie
par tout avouer à la fois jeune et il
fallait le voir et enfin j j allais pas
et en fait non tu as fait beaucoup de
tours et à rien d'acheter maintenant
c'était juste un truc quoi tu as fais
plein de câpres et acheter un truc c'est
que je cherchais quelque chose en
particulier c'est ça ben apparemment tu
me cherchez pas mais bercy a regardé
tout de suite un extrait du spectacle de
patrick de patrick on ne peut pas rire
de tout et je me rappelle je vous jure
avec un ami on l'attendait on était
devant le palais des glaces on voulait
juste le voir on était comme boire
debout dans études quand les meufs voix
m pokora nous les donne à m pokora quoi
on était comme des oufs qua non mais
c'est vrai franchement et voilà bah tu
es toujours - m pokora sache le nombre à
la pomme en péril des balkans les
tatouages
il lui manque les tatouages en est
[Rires]
nous y sommes et femme sandwich à
l'homme jeune icône